Council Road Wall boys chair of
mid-suffolk District Council and I will
be chairing the meeting today
my first of all remind you of some
domestic Arrangements toilets are
situated outside the meeting room
if the fire alarm shut sound please
leave the meeting room by following the
fire exit signs do not re-enter the
building until you are told it is safe
to do so
please switch off all mobile phones or
turn them to silent
I'd like to remind everyone present that
this meter will be broadcast live to the
internet I will be capable of repeated
viewing the whole of the meeting will be
filmed except where there are
confidential or exempt items
if you make a representation a meeting
you'll be deemed by the councils of
consented to being filmed by entering
this meeting you are also consented to
being filmed by the council and the
possible use of the Oz image those
images and sound recorders for
webcasting and or training purposes
the council members of the public and
the Press Mary Court film photograph or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and the Press are not lawfully excluded
marry my members to speak clearly into
the microphones and to not put their
papers over the microphones and also
when speaking not to turn away from the
microphones but to continue to speak
into the microphones can I move to the
agenda please
uh one more point it is my intention to
alter the order of the gender to bring
the sithco item forward to our enable
our visitors to leave if they wish to do
so
apologies for absence
thank you chair I have received
apologies for absence from counselor
Austin Davies councilor Terry Lawrence
councilor David Napier councilor Nikki
wilshere and cancer Janet Pearson
Declarations of Interest by counselors
the monetary officer has granted
dispensation to councils on the board of
directors for the companies for paper
mc2314 capital investment fund company
sifco Capital limited business trading
and performance report
are there any Declarations of Interest
ing
MC's 2311
to confirm the minutes of the meeting
held on 19th of July 2023 for accuracy
only
are there any issues with accuracy
could have a proposal please
Council Miller
could have a second of please
counselor Eben
all those in favor could we take this by
a show of hands
that is carried
uh
chairs announcements uh I refer you to
paper
mc2312 for noting there is a list there
of all the engagements I have undertaken
on your behalf
uh I would like to add the special thank
you for Toby and Stephanie our host for
the barbecue alderco farm and everyone
who attended we made a good start on
fundraising for my two Charities 360
pounds so far
I would also like to mention the Battle
of Britain commemoration parade and
service that I attended on Sunday
it was a powerful reminder of the debt
owed by so many to so few as Pilots of
Britain took to the sky with flyers from
occupied Europe and the Commonwealth to
fight against dictatorship and cruel
despotism
the struggle against tyranny continues
around the world the material support we
are given to the Armed Forces Ukraine
and the shelter to its people
also as we hear on the news about
increased penalties for dress code
violation for Iranian women and their
families we should remember that last
weekend also saw the anniversary of the
arrest brutal beating and death in
custody of a young Iranian woman Gina
Masa amine for allegedly not wearing a
headscarf correctly
the ongoing protests are being brutally
suppressed women and girls are at the
Forefront of this at least 58 school
children have died shot beaten
and poisoned
I have added my name to a statement to
support sent to me by the assertion of
anglo-iranian women in the UK and I'm
asking John to circulate a letter to
allow members to do the same
so let us guard jealously our own civil
liberties and embed the ideals of social
racial and economic Justice in all that
we do thank you
I would like to invite Council Bella
to present his updates
my announcements have been tabled but I
will just read them out and I hope all
counselors manage to enjoy a break over
the summer
I would like to start by marking the
passing of former District councilor
poppy Robertson who is a member of this
Council from 2003 to 2015.
she represented The Stone Market Central
Ward and was a member of the planning
committee and Poppy passed away since
our last council meeting and I'm sure
all members will join me in sending our
condolences to her family and friends
work has been continuing on the
administration's initial plans and we
were delighted last month to launch a
new initiative pride in your place
just given every town and Village in the
district the opportunity to apply for
funding for projects which improve the
appearance and cleanliness of their
community
can be for initiatives like letter
picking sign clearing graffiti removal
and the maintenance or enhancement of
open public spaces and more so I'd like
to remind all councilors that this fund
remains open can I ask you all to
encourage your towns and parishes to get
involved
also in the last month we have announced
two initiatives to support small and new
businesses which are the lifeblood of
our communities
it's Suffolk Council has teamed up with
mentor to order to offer startup
businesses free expert support and
guidance
Council was given funding by the UK
shared Prosperity fund to deliver this
scheme and the program is open so those
in mid-suffolk who are thinking of
starting a business are in the process
of starting a business or have recently
started their business venture
meanwhile businesses in mid-suffolk can
also potentially benefit from a new
round of funding thanks to the rural
England Prosperity fund
small businesses and Community
organizations across the district will
have access to three grants under the
fund
the rural business growth fund the rural
culture and creativity fund and the
rural communities fund
and there's a list of eligible projects
there
small businesses are so important to our
district and I encourage them to visit
our website to check their eligibility
and explore details of these grants and
can I ask members to promote these
schemes in their interactions with
businesses and Parish councils
has also recently responded to a Suffolk
mind survey which identified Stone
Market and the surrounding areas as an
emotional and physical needs hotspot
sounds very interesting doesn't it but
they are awarded awarded 50
000 pounds to local projects which
support community and well-being
we launched the ip14 wellbeing fund and
with our allocated 50 000 through the
Suffolk County council's public mental
health program to 10 local projects and
this will allow them to do more
important work in this area and support
more people
we will continue to work with Partners
to address well-being issues in our
district so that people can lead active
and healthy lives
just want to report that as leader I
represent the district on various
Regional and National bodies in the last
few weeks I've attended meetings of the
east of England local government
Association the District council's
Network where I sit on the executive
board the new Anglia local Enterprise
partnership where I'm a director
representing suffolk's District councils
I've also attended the LGA Leadership
Academy and next week I will be
attending the Suffolk public sector
leaders group
I just want to add to the table papers
that yesterday we received the fine the
fantastic news that part one of our
joint local plan has finally been
declared Sound by the inspector so can I
congratulate all the officers and
members who have worked so long and hard
to get us to this point and we look
forward to seeing the policies in the
jlp make a positive impact
and finally many of you will have seen
the news that baber Council leader Dave
Busby is taking its temporary step back
while he receives treatment for cancer
I'm sure all members will join with me
in wishing him a speedy recovery and we
hope to see him back soon
are there any points are there any
points of clarification
none uh to receive notification of
petitions in accordance with Council
procedure rules
questions by the public in accordance
with Council procedure rules
questions by counselors in accordance
non-received chair
I'd like to move on now to
mc2314 capital investment fund company
business trading and performance report
I would like to welcome sir Christopher
Haworth chair cifco Capital limited
Henry cook director Mark sarginson
director Nigel Golder director strategic
Asset Management jll
councils counselors I would like to deal
with this item in the open part of the
agenda if possible
so can I ask please ask members to
refrain from asking any questions that
relate to individual tenants and the
associated risks
if you wish to ask questions on those
details please can you indicate
and we will move into closed session at
that point before returning to open
session to vote on the recommendation in
the report
I would like to invite Council winch to
introduce paper
mc2314 and to move the recommendations
in the report
okay I'm very aware that there's a
massive briefing pack for cifco and a
lot of people are quite new to it
including myself I'm relatively new to
it so I thought it would be useful just
to give a view from twenty thousand feet
of what I think the most important
aspects of this are so I'm going to try
and touch on five questions question
number one why was it set up in the
first place question number two why is
why did the Green Party oppose it being
set up question number three what are
the highlights in the results question
number four why are we asking you to
approve the business plan in question
number five what do we think going
forward
so the first issue why was Citgo set up
I think really relates to the state of
local government finances England is a
very centralized state with a relatively
low percentage
tax and spend at the local level and
local government's been under squeezed
for quite a long time
so there is a desire to try and create
other forms of income and a scheme
emerge that councils local authorities
could borrow money at a relatively low
rate invest in property and make a
return and the logic of this was it
needs to be seen over decades eventually
you pay off the loans you have the
property and you make a steady income
stream
the green party have been opposed to
setting this up and still are for three
main reasons I think and reason number
one is we don't believe that local
authorities should be investing in
property companies outside the district
and that's a view that the government
effectively has now and our sort of test
of this is if you knocked on a typical
residence door and said are you okay if
we borrow a lot of money and are invest
it in in property outside the district
they'd be a bit concerned about that
the second concern that we had in the
setting up of the company is about we
want all our investment to balance
economic social and environmental issues
and we don't believe that Cisco
did this and the final things about risk
it brings in all sorts of things about
property values interest rates things
that may go wrong with buildings and
we're also worried about the general
expertise within the council outside of
very competent core team so that's
historically why we opposed it
we're not here today to re-run that
debate that's a debate that's been had
we now have a I think everybody knows
and cifco Company which is jointly owned
by mid-suffolk and baber both councils
put 50 million into the company 90 as
low 10 is equity roughly 50 million and
the company now has 21 assets and 81
tenants
um
so what I wanted to do is just highlight
what I think is in the results for 20
22-23 and I picked out four main things
so the first thing that would strike
anyone is the reduction in the asset
value so it went from 94 million to 82.5
million a decline a bit a bit over 12
percent uh when you first look at that a
bit alarming but property values will go
up and down
it would be a problem if you needed to
or wanted to sell some of the assets but
what would be a real real problem if the
income was dropping so in itself it's
not a huge huge um issue but it's a it's
a concern going forward
the second thing that I think is in the
results is the company is generally well
run there's a lot of money being spent
on an advisors and and people trying to
help de-risk the company the income I
think was 5.53 Million up three percent
there's a balanced portfolio different
um geographies different sectors
different sizes the voids rate is lows
and arrears is low all of that kind of
thing so it looks like a well-run jumper
um
two other things I think it's worth
bringing your attention to one is this
deferral of the depth of the payment so
what's going on here is that
um annually the the company pays five
percent of the debt to the council and
some of that has been held back because
we need some working capital in the
company
the money will be paid in a later year
and there has been a hit on the accounts
for the late payment it does raise the
question of how much working capital is
required in the company going forward
the other thing that's worth drawing
your attention to is there's a table of
inter the impact of interest rates
and that clearly shows that the margin
to the council not the company
gets squeezed if interest rates go up
now I've seen today that after 14 rises
in a row they haven't risen so in the
very short term it looks like interest
rates are coming down
but if you look at that table it shows
you the impact of each half a percent
racking of the interest rate
um why are we asking you to approve the
business plan
um
the basic first of all what is the
business plan saying as I read it it's
basically saying carry on what's been
going on over the last couple of years
and it picks out four things monitoring
the voids rate very carefully
controlling the spread in the portfolio
investing in certain properties to
improve their relap value and trying to
roll out the EPC changes to get
everything to EPC C Level by 2027.
two reasons why we believe we should
approve the business plan one is we as
we now are we oppose setting up the
company but now as we now own it we need
it to be run in a way that limits risk
and brings in the maximum of income for
the council we're also concerned if we
haven't got a business plan I mean we're
halfway through the year as it happens
but it makes our governance of the
company quite weak because we haven't
got any yards stick to judge the company
by
where do we think we're going in the
future so at the moment we are trying to
take advice internal external on a
number of issues some of them came up at
the overview and scrutiny committee but
there are things around the overall risk
of the company impact of interest rates
what would be the impact of selling an
asset and using the money for other
things try and find out what what our
options are we're hoping to do that in
the October time frame and the idea is
and we obviously would have to do
anything in discussion with babe because
they're joint owners of this company to
feed that into the next business
planning cycle so our aim is to do
something in an informed and a
structured way so just a very quick
summary we've got two steps here Step
One is we'd like to approve this
business plan and create a stable base
that we've already got
and step two we will then look at what
our options are going forward
and some of you will be thinking it all
sounds a bit vague I'm not sure what
they're going to do but I think it's
obvious what we'd like to do is Balance
Financial prudency with some of the
reservations that we had setting up the
company in the first place how easy that
is to do we we will see going forward
so I'd like to propose that we we votes
and notes the accounts for 22-23 and
that we approve the business plan for
23.24
thank you councilor
could I have a second please
counselor
thank you chair I'll be seconding this
report and I'd like to reserve my right
to speak thank you
councilor uh we'll now move to questions
uh just remind you it counselors may ask
as many questions as they wish however
they must be relevant to the subject
under discussion and must be a question
on page 103 of our pack
uh under portfolio transactions
states that the 10 rent reviews were
achieved at 14.93 above the estimated
rental values at the event date
now 10 rent reviews strikes with a
decent number you know statistically
valid so do these statistics suggest to
our experts here that with the
valuations collating to rental returns
our overall ervs and therefore overall
year-end portfolio values must have been
done on a very conservative basis and
that perhaps our unrealized Capital
losses May in fact be potentially
overstated thank you
thank you
and Magic older General thank you for
your question
um the the first starting point I
suppose is that the evaluation is at a
point in time
is set up March
um the reflection of the
additional income that we've managed to
achieve comes from two sources
principally is a timing issue and
secondly we've been
create
evidence which supports a higher value
than there was available at the time
that the portfolio is valued
so it's a matter of active
Asset Management we would call it
to generate additional income
do you have a further question
so I'm not sure if that answers question
as to whether the perhaps the unrealized
capital losses may be potentially
overstated
in the accounts this year then they
potentially could be I think it's what
you're saying so it is is the portfolio
valued in a more conservative way rather
than a bullish way I I think as Nigel is
stated valuations are always a snapshot
in time so they're always at that at
that point of time they also tend to
Look Backwards rather than looking
forward because they're looking at the
evidence that has accrued over the
previous say three four months time so
they're always going to to Look
Backwards I think in relation to your
point about the um
the rent reviews and the lease renewals
that we've stated the valuation this
year would have taken those into account
because they're things that had occurred
um so I think it's unlikely I think the
valuation that we've got as at the 31st
of March is a fair one there's all
there's all degree of
um variation in terms of those figures
if you have different values valuing
them they'll come up with a figure
that's within a reasonable range but
there will always be a slightly
different interpretation but I think
it's a fair one in in reality
thank you very much for your answers
are there any further questions
uh Council scarf
okay
um one thing I didn't ask when I was at
scrutiny committee was about the
investment guidelines
um
page 135
we are in breach on no more than 35
percent of the portfolio to be held in a
specific sector at any one time I I know
the reason why we hold that because
actually that's the best performing
sector in the Market at the moment but
should we consider a change in the
investment guidelines or are this is
that literally the investment guidelines
for the length of the time that we have
the portfolio so should we be
considering changing that because anyone
who looks at that thinks well they've
breached that
your advice please
thank you councilor so the investment
guidelines was set up particularly when
we were in the acquisitive phase of
settings if Co-op and so they were the
original guidelines that we looked to to
use we did as a board consciously decide
to be overweighted in the industrial
sector because it was the better
performing sector and I think because
we're not looking at um
we're not in an acquisitive phase
anymore I think it's fair to have those
investment guidelines almost reflecting
what our strategy was moved previously I
think if we were to ever to become
acquisitive again we might want to look
at those investment guidelines and see
whether we wanted to change them you
know their broadly Sound Investment
guidelines but it's about responding to
the market and the circumstances and
opportunities there are at the time so
we potentially would look at them in the
future
if we were ever inquisitive again
are there any further questions
foreign
we'll now move to debate councilors only
be allowed to speak once for three
minutes and this will be timed
who'd like to start please Council
caxton
thank you very much um chairman
um I will be voting for this business
plan I'm a big fan of Pacifico I think
um
the portfolio holder talks about looking
at economic environmental and social
um positives within the um investment
but all that will come later the um this
is a great legacy this um cifco um
portfolio there'll be um
there'll be counselors that aren't even
born yet having conversations on how we
can make this portfolio more ethical in
many other ways long since long after
we've paid off the money for it it's um
I think the management of this is
absolutely excellent we looked at this
in um scrutiny and um I I personally was
very impressed by um what was going on
especially the EPC the work being done
for epcs it's it's all very good but um
yeah it's it's a fantastic Legacy for
future generations and residents of
mid-suffolk
um so thank you very much
are there any further
points counselor wait
thanks
very much um can I just say
congratulations councilwins that was a
great introduction and actually it took
me back to the way we debated this only
about six nine months ago in this
chamber and much of what you said was
exactly what the administration back
then said so I guess this is the first
green U-turn in what four months so
congratulations we're delighted to have
you on board
Council
Council wins John do you want to respond
to this I rather further put yeah I
think it's obviously sorry I can't I
think can you serve a counselor string
of first
thanks Chad uh
no uh I just conducted slightly reflect
Hicks uh and actually quote his Deputy
leader at the County Council in
reflecting upon the green LED
Administration here he said so far it's
been all rather sensible when he wrote
In The Spectator last month thank you
chair
thank you chair
um
and thank you councilor winch for that
very very comprehensive overview of the
report
um as has already been discussed in
opposition we were opposed in principle
to the concept of cifco
borrowing money from the public works
loan board to invest in commercial
property outside of the district and I
could say that the government was
persuaded by the force of our argument
in that they stopped The pwlb Lending
for this type of activity but now that
we're in administration we have
inherited responsibility for sifco
um some people may have expected that we
would immediately withdraw given our
objections but this would not be a wise
or prudent or sensible move however what
we do think is sensible is to review
what the company is doing and by the
time the next business plan is presented
be clear about what our long-term
strategy is and that is set out in
paragraph 4.9 of the report
we do need to be clear-eyed about both
the rewards that come from cifco which
are real and the risks and I'll explain
why
the premise of cifco is that the council
was able to borrow money
plea from the pwlb
and then lend that to an armsense
company who would purchase commercial
property for return
so the return to the council exists in
that Gap
between how much interest we pay for the
money we've borrowed and the interest we
receive back from cifica
that's all very well if we had done what
was originally intended and borrowed all
the money at fixed long-term low
interest rates unfortunately that is not
what has happened
some of the borrowing is locked down in
this way but a substantial amount is
short-term borrowing where we are we are
exposed to rises in interest rates
and as rates have risen they are eating
away at the return on the Enterprise
how will the company is run
I think we can all see from this very
comprehensive report that we have an
excellent board of directors and a very
professional set of advisors who are
managing the property portfolio very
well
the properties are being improved rents
are being revised upward where possible
voids are low and rent arrears are small
and I'm very grateful to Sir Christopher
and his team for the work they are doing
but we do need to be aware of the
structural risk that is inherent in the
cifco operation and the borrowing we
have done to fund it and we need to
monitor that very very carefully however
on that basis I will be voting to
approve the business plan thank you
chair
Council wife
thank you chair
um well I welcome councilor when she's
um acceptance of sifco going forward I'm
very relieved to hear that particularly
I welcome his realistic view of the
unrealized capital losses and I welcome
them because I've seen some quite
hysterical comments on local social
media about that about officers and
members
like playing in the casino with this
sort of money
quite the opposite of what Pacifica
actually is which is a well diverse and
long-term investment plan so I'm glad to
hear he's not in that count
interesting comment on the interest
rates and for a long time I was saying
yes we whilst interest rates will learn
we should borrow along and fix them but
I think the reality is that this Council
potentially could make a shed load of
profit from Gateway 14 The Profit is
cash
so if we've got that
Cash Coming Down the Line in the future
a year or two then why would you want to
borrow long term for 10 or 20 years so
that's that's my take on interest rates
anyway
and just to cancel the ministry's point
where he says about knocking on doors
and asking residence I think it's the
question of what question do you
actually ask the resident if I knocked
on someone's door and said look what do
you think of a long-term
well-diversified risk investment that
will generate cash and income to
subsidized Council services
so in other words say a tenant in Milton
Keynes is Croatian attending middle
Keynes is putting women into this
Council to subsidize services or tenant
in Epsom or Brentwood or wherever is
actually subsidizing and paying part of
the cost of emptying your bins so you're
not paying the full amount yourself this
commercial tenant is doing that and I
think they would welcome that and
applaud it and uh so I say I think it's
just a question of what question you ask
the resident as to what answer you get
so that's why I taken it I very much
support see if I have done from day one
and I look forward to vote in favor of
it thank you
if
if we have no further points I'm going
to ask councilor when should we ask any
further ah councilor burn would you like
to speak now
um thank you thank you chair um as as
everyone's aware of we were never in
favor of setting up a separate
Investment Company to invest in
commercial property outside of our
district and now we're in administration
we are reviewing how this is working and
how it can be improved
the key paragraph from the report for
you is 4.9 where that ambition is
clearly laid out
in an Ideal World this business plan
which is for the current Financial year
should have been presented and agreed
well before that year started I
understand there are particular
accounting reasons why it's not the case
but we do need to try to bring that
timing forward as much as we can
secondly in recent years as has been
mentioned increased interest interest
rates in recent times rather interest
rates have increased greatly and much of
the funding supporting zipco over 50 of
it is from short-term borrowing this is
a concern and as is shown on page 63 and
we do need to monitor that very closely
thirdly it's previously been agreed with
sifco to delay part of the payments due
to the council as my colleague Council
winch has mentioned in the short term
and while this is continuing as shown in
the report again this needs to be
closely monitored
we do need to continue with upgrading
the portfolio to a decent Energy
Efficiency to standard despite the
government's latest flip-flop on this
and partly but partly because this makes
sense and fits with our own Ambitions
and the plan and these plans are in
place but partly because this policy is
likely to change again anyway because I
suspect government will flip-flop again
before the next before the general
election so we can't just keep changing
our plans according to central
government whims
but hopefully we'll be able to do
something about Energy Efficiency long
before the next generation of councilors
are born
um but this requires Investments which
has to be funded through sifco
so while we don't agree in principle we
do need to work with what we've
inherited and we need to improve it
where we can while continuing to focus
on sensible financial management and
ensuring that we can meet our program of
fostering resilient thriving communities
putting environmental and social
responsibilities at the heart of
everything we do thank you
thank you councilor
um councilor which would you like to
Summit please I'll be very quick I think
we could talk about this forever the
green Administration are never going to
be entirely comfortable with Cisco
but we need to be realistic about where
we are we've inherited a property
company that's very well run
um and but we do want to shape it in the
future in certain directions that are
more in line with our principles that's
where
thank you Council winch uh thank you I
will now ask the corporate manager
governance and Civic office to conduct
the electronic vote
thank you chair that vote is now showing
in blue for councilors to cast their
vote
and just to say that you will need to
page down because it's changed we have
changed the order so
yeah can I take your vote verbally then
councilor please
thank you
thank you chair that is 29 votes for
thank you that is carried
uh
no I think you've just have a pause for
a few moments while our guests from
cifco may take the opportunity to leave
they may stay for the rest of the
meeting if they like
foreign
now move on to item MC
2313 uh this is a treasury management
report 22 23. I would like to invite
Council Matheson to introduce his item
and to move the recommendations on the
agenda
thank you very much chair
well this is the
um joint treasury management report for
the year ended 31st of March 2023
um and um it covers the position of
across that year provides details of
performance the effects of decisions
taken during that period and compliance
with the council's treasury management
policies
explains the factors affecting the
strategy and activities including the
regulatory framework the economic
conditions the interest rates and the
liquidity risks it was considered in
detail at the Joint audit and standards
committee on 31st of July
committee received a presentation from
David Green of Arling close that's our
treasury advisors
and this was followed by a lengthy
debate with members asking many
questions
the economic backdrop for the year was
characterized by high oil gas and
commodity prices ongoing High inflation
and its impact on consumers cost of
living
and no imminent end in sight to the
Russia Ukraine hostilities and its
Associated impacts and the highest level
of strikes in industrial action the
country has seen for many years
interest rates have climbed with the
bank rate increasing from 0.75 at the
beginning of this year
Financial year in March 22 up to 4.25 by
March 23 and obviously a bit more since
um the bank of England increased oh
sorry it's there the bank of England
increased it further to 5.25
in August
and um at that time the majority of the
committee judge that there might be
further increase is required I think I
heard councilman winch say that in fact
there was good news that it was going to
be stabilized today thank you
so more specifically for our Council
um mid-suffolk has reduced its net
borrowing by 8.8 million
um
and um that's net and in fact we've
reduced
um by 12.6 million and that's been
offset by reducing our investments by
3.8 million I think perhaps I'd just say
at that point for for new members
particularly that the
um you know this is that this is all our
cash flow treasury management all the
different activities of the council and
the companies that we own
um all that cash is being managed
by our treasury team
all our investment activities were
undertaken in accordance with the
approved counterparty list
that's the people we borrow from and
lend to and the council's investment
activities included average returns that
you can find in appendix C on the report
the council's pulled funds
excluding 91 series that's one of the
companies have experienced a drop in
valuation but an increase in the rate of
return compared to 2122
the council has complied with the upper
limit for interest rate exposure
the investment activity undertaken for
the year was done so in Prior order of
security and liquidity over yield
as prescribed in the treasury management
strategy
banking activities undertaken were
within the daily bank account limits
except for one occasion when the daily
limit with the council's bank lies was
exceeded this was due to money being
received
into the account after the cutoff time
for transfers into the money markets and
was rectified the following day
as I mentioned earlier the report has
already been considered in detail by The
Joint audit standards committee but I'm
happy to take any further questions from
members on the report and I'm pleased to
say that we have um we have
um the interim corporate manager for
finance and our resources and finance
director with us to help with answers
thank you
I have a second of please
um oh gosh
um councilman
um
I'd happily like to Second The Proposal
from councilor Matheson I remember on
the day that we did have some Lively
debates and there was definitely some
constructive and challenging questions
that we
sort of through towards Bob and
thankfully today Bob is joined by
Melissa so he's got a bit of a backup
but I'd happily second this venture
uh we will now move to questions
Council Council caxton
thank you very much Mr chairman now I'm
not sure if this is directed at
councilor Matheson but is part of the um
report in the environmental implications
says that um the cabinet pushes for fund
managers to filter investments in
respect to ESG considerations and then
in the following um
paragraph it says the joint audit and
standards committee recognize that any
decision to withdraw funds should be
balanced against Financial Prudence so
could you explain to me exactly what
that's telling me on there place I'll
I'll never try that one myself chair
um the I think the point essentially is
that this this Administration does want
to align our investments which are in
our term significant as a council with
our priorities for for um environment
climate
um remediation let's call it and um so
we do want to look at that
and we have a report
which will be
before the committee on Monday
to have a look at what the possibilities
are for doing that better
um
without
you know two significantly impacting our
finances and the
the reality is as the report says that
there is we do we are have currently got
um a
um what should we say a
a reduction in the value of our our
investments and
um
so we will have to see whether you know
we're going to declare that loss
by
changing changing our investments in
alignments I said with our priorities or
not and that's something we'll be
discussing on Monday
thank you chair uh can you tell us if we
still have investment
fuels and if so how much
thank you
um my understanding is that that we do
and I'm sure that our officers will be
able to provide a little more
information
um
without without some
getting into huge detail because I know
it's actually quite a complicated answer
thank you chairman and thank you for the
question counselor
um we don't have a detailed breakdown
within appendix C we've listed the funds
that the council holds money in but we
haven't got full d
immediately available of
particular
other Investments that are within those
portfolios
I I can't give you a complete answer
tonight in terms of unfortunately
um thank you for that it was a little
bit hard to write can I just remind
people just to make sure that their
laptops are not in front of the
microphones and they speak because
otherwise I've got a fan behind which
makes it very hard to hear as well
thank you
are there any further questions
uh then
then we will now move to the debate
councils only be allowed to speak once
for three minutes and this will be timed
uh Council Ebon
um thank you chair
um I'd like to just make a couple of
points if I may
um with regards to the
um
the paragraph 11.3 on page 24 which was
about looking further at the
environmental social and governance
considerations this is something that
we've been pushing for for a long time
and even though it was at the cabinet in
the previous administration two years
ago it's only just now that we're able
to get a report on this from our um
treasury advisors and I'm really pleased
and thank good thanks to officers for
obtaining that report and I would urge
any um member that's interested it's
being discussed as my colleague said at
the audience standards committee on
Monday and it's a really good detailed
report that details out what our funds
are invested in what are the potentials
where there might be Financial
considerations and I would urge people
to because it's a confidential paper so
you'll be able to as members you'll be
able to have a look at that but I'd urge
you to attend that meeting if you want
more information
but but equally with it within that
um
one of the things that we have to
consider is to ensure that there is you
know if if any changes are made then
that is got properly considered all the
financial considerations because as we
mentioned the previous one we're looking
at very sensible financial management
and we need to be very clear on that but
I'm really pleased to see that coming
forward
even though it's taken two years to get
here
um and secondly I just like to make the
point um which does relate also to the
previous
um paper on on sifco is that our
short-term borrowing is quite
um extensive if you look at appendix a
page 31
um we've got 24 million pounds in
short-term borrowing and obviously the
issue with interest rates as we know
they've potentially stabilized today but
who knows what will happen in the future
and I just think we need to make the
point that we need to keep a close eye
on that
um and um
I would urge again anyone interested to
kind of have a good look at that and um
make sure we're looking at that
carefully but those are a couple of
things that I think we need to ensure
that we do within this
um within the treasury management system
thank you
are there any further
points people would like to make
right
um
I think Council Patrick have you had
anything further to say
nothing further Jeff
yeah Council Masterson
yes thank you I I've um also nothing
further to add other than that I've just
lost the papers again
um yeah there are there are two
um there are two
items for noting and um
which you've got before you so I will
urge you to
to vote for them thank you
I will now as a corporate manager
governance and Civic office to conduct
the electronic vote
thank you chair just to clarify there's
actually three items 3.1 3.2 and 3.3 so
if counselors could cast their vote
thank you
councilor Marriott are you having
technical problems would you like me to
take your vote
and cancer winch
that's great
chair that's 29 votes for that is
unanimous
I would now like to move on to
item 14
mc2350 Mitch Suffolk state of the
district report 2023.
I'd like to invite Council Mellon to
induce the paper
mc2315 and to move the recommendation in
the report
I'm very happy to introduce this new
report and councilors will have to get
used to seeing something of this sort
every year from now on
the state of the district report which I
hope members have had time to study is a
fascinating document
brought together a massive amount of
data
an Insight from various sources and
research and it presents this
information in a very digestible way
the report is presented as part of the
evidence for the corporate plan refresh
which is commencing next month
but we need to clearly understand where
we are before we can set the direction
of travel for the future and I think
this report does that not only with
high-level statistics
but also some fascinating granular
detail
if I know Mr chairman I would like to
draw members attention to a few key bits
of information in the report hopefully
this will wet your appetite to explore
further
Miss avak has just over 102 000
residents living in 44 000 households
is that on average people in mid-suffolk
live longer than the national average
we have better levels of Health and 87
of us are satisfied with where we live
on the other side we have less access to
the fastest Broadband speeds
few fewer of us have a degree level
qualification in the national average
and we have much less tree cover than
other parts of the country
you dig around in the report you will
find a wealth of interesting detail as
someone who grows and sells fruit and
vegetables in the other part of my life
I was very pleased to read on page 13 of
the report that in mid-suffolk more of a
thief are five a day than the national
average very good news
one other fascinating fact that I would
just drop in to finish on page four of
the report we learned that 27 of homes
are occupied by a single person and
across the country 31 of homes are
single occupancy
I'll just highlight that because we are
constantly told we are living in a
housing crisis and we need to build more
homes
I think I could be pretty confident in
saying there are enough bedrooms for
everyone
just a thought to ponder
it's a rapport very very well put
together that gives us a baseline for
the corporate plan refresh I'd like to
thank the Strategic policy team and in
particular Chris Holmes for putting this
together in such an accessible way and
I'm happy to propose the recommendation
3.1 that we note the context of the
mid-suffolk state of the district report
2023 and we endorse its publication on
the council's website next month thank
you chair
councilman could have a second to please
to
Council Davis
[Music]
thank you councilor Davies uh before we
move on to general questions I've got a
question I'd quite like to ask I did
have a I was confess a very quickly
through the report uh
there's no information as far as I could
find on students progression
that's
people under the age of 18 and their
attainment in schools within our
district
if it's okay tell I'll refer this
question to the um the officer president
if she can
or they can provide an answer
thank you chair sorry quick conferring
there
um yes though we I don't have
information on that in this year we've
obviously
um tried to keep the report as concise
as possible at this year but we could
take that away and reflection it to see
if that's some information that we can
include in it moving forward so we can
have those discussions
um with counselors in the production for
it next year
thank you are there any further
questions
uh Council Linda
how many GPS there
there are per resident in the area
couldn't find that information in the
actual report but it would be a very
interesting and important thing to know
about for future planning and all of
that not least as we can rejoice in the
fact that we have a longer longevity
than the average of the country
thank you
is that something we have information on
um yes sir we do have information
supporting our joint local plan on
health infrastructure needs and so we we
can look to see what information we have
there and forecasting um forward we
don't obviously want to um we don't want
to be kind of repeating information
across but we can have a look into it
just to see how we can get that
visibility and that connection obviously
for existing information that we hold
and signposting to that through state in
the district report
thank you
damn me
yes counselor yeah I thought this was a
really excellent Report with all sorts
of interesting things in it
um it would be useful on the Housing
section to have a little bit more on
affordability so maybe comparing average
salary with with rents typically shown
as you know average salary as a
percentage of rental values and maybe
also comparing the local housing
allowance which is used for benefit
calculations What proportion of housing
actually is available at those rates
conflicts
thanks um yeah I mean we're merging into
debate and question but but I mean I I
think this I agree it's a great report
it's good to have all I just ask is when
we put it on the website could we maybe
have a link to the Suffolk Observatory
because so much of this is actually
coming out of this energy and that's
updated daily weekly monthly so then
rather than just having an annual some
of this information we
and I know that the figures wouldn't be
available from the OMS but
can because of the changes in what was
collected by in the most recent census
and would it be possible to have a bit
where figures are separated by gender to
acknowledge that figures on
um available for non-binary people and
just to tie up with what was in the most
recent census recorded in the most
recent census
thank you councilor
Council
yeah I think we can we can look at that
I'll hand over to the offices
yeah certainly we can add an open
interpretation there um where data is
presented based on gender
thank you counselor over
tree canopy
cup is 8.5
quite a lot lower than the average
across England of 16.3 percent I
wondered what the reasons for that are
Council thank you chair um
one of the reasons we're very aware of
the tree canopy is cover and the
percentage it's because we've we've had
that work done the survey the canopy
survey done and we're able to even
disaggregate that down to to Ward level
but it does give you that kind of real
level of granular detail but it's also a
challenge because we realize that we are
behind other districts and and we're
below the national average I know that's
something that we would certainly want
to improve over the next few years and
there's been there's there's tree
planting going on by the County Council
by this District by Farmers by lots of
community groups as well
um and there's two ways I think which we
can improve the tree cover one is
improve uh trees in in developments so
that's a better landscaping and more
tree cover within within the environment
and then more trees in the countryside
in general I know in my in my Village we
don't have a wood it just seems like
really strange to live in the
countryside and not have a wood in the
village so we do need more tree cover
it's certainly one of the priorities
we'll be pushing
um and I think we're you know we're
alongside a lot of other organizations
including the County Council in doing
that
that's a problem yes if I can just um
follow up on on my comments um we're
still at the moment sorry yes thank you
so let's have that later on then
have we got any further questions
I'll now move on to debate and give
Council throughout the floor right
brilliant
thank you very much doing things the
right in the right order yes
um so um I found that was quite an
interesting question as well and um for
anyone who's scrutinized um the maps
another thing that stands out is that um
well in my ward for example we have at
least three triple sis
um we have middlewood Bollywood and
Priestly wood
um owned by various uh ones owned by the
Woodland trust another by the Suffolk
Wildlife trust and another one is
privately owned I believe
um
in in other in other words so I've got
like
um clusters large clusters of sort of
Green Space clusters of canopy but
there's not really very much linking it
in between
when you look at other awards for
example Clayton and Barham which has the
higher sort of level of tree canopy in
our district
you'll see that it's less clustered and
kind of more dispersed kind of tree
cover
um well some of it's all follows that
linear kind of corridor along the river
gipping but there is generally more
dispersed tree cover dotted around in
that wood in any case and I think that
the key thing is here is that a lot of
the land in Suffolk is agricultural it's
under intensive farming practices and
what we really need to do to sort of
start off with perhaps is is in filling
some of those um hedgerows where there
are gaps in those hedgerows to
strengthen some of those Wildlife
corridors and and that would
um
sort of help to improve our canopy cover
as well we'll need to work with private
landowners I might insist as well as
with looking at what we can do with our
own land as well
I think that's a good example of our
accurate data and information can inform
policy do we have any more points we'd
like to make Council whiter
thank you chairman um I have to say I do
think this is an excellent and
informative document and I commend the
officers who have claytoned all this
information it's a fascinating read for
members staff and residents and I'm
happy to endure since publication on the
council's website in October the reality
being of course it's already on the
website as part of these meetings public
documents so it would actually be a bit
awkward if we don't endorse it
like our prime minister I'm a convinced
that programmatic advocate for global
net zero so I read the section on
emissions and housing with special
interest
it's heartening to see the 36 reduction
in mid-supper commissions from 2005 to
2021 we domestic emissions being down 39
percent
transport and agriculture 68.2
commissions accounts for over two
two-thirds of those missions so I'm sure
in those areas there are real challenges
to move into Net Zero whilst maintaining
the consent of our residents
likewise on the domestic side under
housing we see that 99 of residents have
Central Heating
and at 30.3 nearly a third use oil as a
single source of heating
now since moving house in November last
year I had fallen into that category and
I'm sure that many of our residents like
myself
would have been mightily relieved at
hearing the extension to the time frame
to replace any failed oil boilers given
both current technology and the capacity
of the heat pump industry at present
with three quarters of our residents
currently relying on oil and gas for
heating
there are real challenges in moving to
Net Zero that will need us to take a
pragmatic proportionate and realistic
approach both nationally and locally so
I trust the district council we will
thank you
I said I just
just repeat the recommendations and the
content of the mid Suffolk state of the
district report and endorse its
publication thank you
do you have any further points to make
um councilor Patrick I believe you did
introduce second it and but would you
have you ever got any further cups
our beggy pardon Council Davis
um I think I just wanted to to make sort
of um I value this report a great deal
and I also wanted to state that
from the statistics reported we can see
that the majority of us are living in a
home that we own with spare bedrooms
we're happy well educated have jobs and
live in low crime areas
um but also I wanted to point out that
this same report Port will show you that
there are
four and a half thousand people living
on their own over the age of 66. there
is difficulty being there a GP people
seen
um as in a vulnerable group do not have
access to the internet nearly 6 000
households are facing fuel poverty and
nearly 6 000 people are having Universal
Credit to top up their wages
20 of mid-suffolk children are living in
poverty a hundred of those were homeless
last year so I think by collating this
information and seeing the stark
contrast it's important that we see what
our job is and what our role is in
camping
thank you very much Council Davis
Council Miller
yeah thank you chair and thank you for
all the different people who've
contributed to the debate I do think the
information gathered in this report is
really useful there is a moment in time
and as councilor Hicks has reminded us
we can access constantly updated
information on the software office of
data analytics website
um
the website the the information in the
report is encouraging in many ways but
it also as counselor Davis has just said
is it does also outline the scale of the
challenge and that's um what we want to
set out as we refresh the corporate plan
in the next few months so we can see a
very clear direction of travel for this
Administration for this Council so
police can ask you to vote in favor
thank you
it's a corporate manager governance and
Civic officer to conduct the electronic
votes
showing in blue counts as you will need
to tab down to find the vote thank you
councilor can I take your vote as well
please
no if I can take it
lovely thanks
chair that is 29 nine votes for that is
unanimous
to invite the invite the corporate
manager governance and Civic office to
introduce this report
thank you chair so this report asks
Council to consider the principle of
appointing political assistance for
political groups within the framework of
the local government and Housing Act
1989.
and if it agreed outlines the
arrangements for the appointment of
those political assistants should any
group wish to take that opportunity
if the political assistance posts are
created they would be responsible to the
appropriate group leader on a day-to-day
line basis management online management
basis and that would report directly to
the director of Law and governance
section 3.1 of the report details the
stringent conditions that need to be
followed if the principle of appointing
political assistance is approved
groups will only qualify for assistance
if they comprise at least 10 percent of
the membership of the authority and are
one of of the three largest groups on
the council for mid-suffolk all three
political groups qualify and can request
a political assistant if they so choose
there can be no more than three such
appointments and only one for each group
appointments can only be made if posts
are allocated to each group even though
a group may choose not to make an
appointment
the terms of ruminate remuneration are
stipulated in the local government
assistance for political groups
remuneration England ordered 2021 which
provides a maximum amount which you can
pay the assistance
the funding for that will be taken out
of the councilor allowances budget and
just to to make that clear it says
expenses budget really is actually the
alliance budget
which has Headroom due to a reduction in
the number of cabinet members and the
reduction in the number of planning
committees so Council I asked if you um
would like to discuss and debate that
matter thank you
yeah thank you Mr chairman I'm happy to
propose the recommendations of the
report I'm happy to speak at the
appropriate moment
thank you councilman could have a second
to please
Council Stringer
thank you I'd like to Second this motion
and uh reserve my right to speak thank
you chair thank you councilor Stringer
uh we will now move to questions
counselors may ask as many questions as
we wish however they must be relevant to
the subject under discussion and must be
a question
Council custom
thank you very much and Mr chairman and
um Jan has um explained this in a bit
more detail but I still quite have
haven't quite got my head around it no
appointments can be made until posts
have been established for all qualifying
groups now I'm I'm still not quite sure
what that means could you explain that
further
thank you chat yeah so we need to
allocate a post to each of the
qualifying group that doesn't mean to
say that each group has to appoint to
that but we need to say actually three
three groups qualify and that they you
know each group is allocated a post so
that's what it means otherwise um if you
don't specify that you could you know it
could be that one group just goes away
and says oh well I'll have one but it's
actually means that all three groups of
this Council can are qualified so can
appoint and we would allocate that
position to each group but it's your
choice it's down to each group's choice
if they wish to appoint
any further questions
uh
as the questions have finished
we will now move to debate councils will
only be allowed to speak once for three
minutes and this will be timed
Council Mellon
thank you chair
um
Mr chairman political assessments are
are a fairly common site across the
local government family some local
authorities have them others do not we
haven't had them previously here but now
we would like to hence why this report
was requested by the administration and
I'm grateful for the officers for
drawing it up
if you've read the report you will see
that the rules surrounding this this
sort of appointment are fairly stringent
the role is politically restricted
term of employment is limited to the
council term and there is also guidance
that encourages councils to carry out a
value for money job assessment before
the role is advertised and recruits it
to
with the recommendation that wherever
possible they should be employed on a
part-time basis
the key point on this issue is that at
3.1 the third bullet point
role provides assistance to the members
of a political political group in the
discharge of their functions as members
of the authority
to paraphrase a political assistant will
help counselors to fulfill their role to
do the job of being a counselor well
there are many ways in which they could
do this providing information
researching ideas bringing best practice
from other councils and other
organizations providing support and
communication and organizing the group
our group is discussed and agreed that a
part-time political assistant would help
us to be better counselors and therefore
the organization and the district will
benefit as a result
the rules on this mean that given each
of the council each group on the council
has at least 10 percent of the seats
that all groups here could choose to
have one we accept that there is a cost
to employing new members of staff
however I should point out that there
have been substantial savings made from
the previous administration by having
only one planning committee and by
having less cabinet members
officers will still have to carry out a
value for money assessment and this
paper simply establishes the principle
but I'm happy to propose the the three
recommendations in the report thank
any further points councils would like
to make
Council Whitehead
thank you chair
um when reporting back to Parish
councils over the summer has not been a
great deal to tell them and then there
are other modest spend associated with
the pride in your place proposal so I've
been legally awaiting the first more
substantive initiative coming from this
new green Administration
I must confess I wasn't expecting it to
be a request to officers to bring
forward the recruitment for political
assistant to support the leader in his
cabinet
in my nine years in a cabinet role I've
never personally felt the need to have a
political assistant
when I looked at my computer today I
found an electronic folder called intro
speeches containing 108 species I'd
written myself over the years to
introduce reports to Cabinet full
Council scrutiny member briefings I
remember working over weekends and or
late into the night finalizing those
speeches but never once did I desire to
offer that burden onto other officers or
a political assistant
be prepared in order to write speeches
and to answer questions I've had to
spend time liaising with the relevant
officers but I believe that worked
better directly rather than using an
intermediary between us
have no doubt a great deal of my time
would have been saved had I been able
just to say to a political assistant
have my speech ready for me for
reviewing on Friday
having a political assistant would also
save me a great deal of time on Google
doing my own research
I'm saying goes time is money
so I wonder will the independent
remuneration panel now be asked to
reassess cabinet members special
responsibility allowances should they be
given a political assistant to write
their speeches to do their research to
run group meetings and generally be
there paid Pas and apparently and I have
to pinch myself here these Pas can even
do the leaders constituency work
caseload
well I understand the causes Initiative
for the current year will come out the
approved budgets as there'd only be
three to four months worth expenditure
in 23 24.
in the budget 2425 that will have to do
the heavy lifting for this proposal
possibly to the tune of 130 000 pounds
plus if three full-time Pas are employed
for a full year
now our current four-year medium-term
Financial strategy assumes the
continuity of the previous two years of
council tax freezes
is the new Administration do instead
decide to increase cow's attacks next
year then clearly this additional new
expense must be a factor in that
equation
well I hope what I'm just say in some at
least in some way explains why I won't
be voting for this initiative and just
the avoidance of Doubt these are my own
words not to political assistance thank
you
I've got any further points you'd like
to make Council councilor Hicks thank
you um
four and a half thousand employees with
a budget of 700 million pounds mid
Suffolk is a very small Council in
relation so I think it is only
proportionate that it should be a
part-time role but Council Mellon talks
about value for money surely the best
value for money would be to appoint a
full cabinet who could do all the work
and then you wouldn't need a researcher
to back you up and support you that
would be far cheaper
thank you Council it's councilman
thank you very much chair
I think um
in the just to come back on a couple of
points I think in the previous
administration
um councilman Whitehead may have written
his own speeches I'm fully aware that
many of his colleagues did not and the
officers wrote them but I think that is
not something that we'd expect a
political assistant to do we're looking
at research at best practice and many
district councils across the country
including East Suffolk have political
assistance and I think it's safe to say
in this group we would not be looking
for a full-time role we were looking for
a part-time role
if we were to take on a part-time
political assistant that would cost just
over 20 000 pounds a year
we're currently saving the council 24
000 pounds a year we in fact we've
already saved the council 12 000 pounds
a year with our um difference in cabinet
plus the fact that with the um
expenses allowances
um in the past many councilors would
have driven and claimed mileage
um in our group many people take the
train which is a cheaper way in terms of
allowances so we've saved at least five
thousand so far on that so there are
savings that have been made within the
allowances but I think the most
important point is that it's about
Effectiveness you're looking for Best
Practices we're wanting to look across
the council I mean how many times have I
stood up in this chamber and asked the
members of the then Administration what
was the best practice from another
Council where have we looked at what do
we what are we doing and not had a good
answer and I think we owe it to our
residents actually to be able to provide
more of those instances of best practice
to be able to look at those research and
ideas that perhaps aren't fully formed
and we don't want to bring officers in
on the ideas that are maybe not quite
ready to be prepared and bought to
council we want to kind of investigate
the ideas a bit more and I think it
would provide very good value for money
and just to reaffirm we would only be
looking at a part-time assistant
certainly not full-time and we we I will
certainly be supporting this report
thank you chair
thank you
thank you councilor uh I've got a new
further points people would like to make
uh
Council scarf
thank you
um well I know we've interested
the majority of posters that we have at
the council are shared posts and I think
I would be more in favor of it had
Baylor Council decided to actually go
ahead because I think the numbers then
make more sense with nine or ten perhaps
in a group I think there's more
legitimacy to having an assistant
at the point that the Administration has
made about a part-time assistant then
leads me to think well how could a group
as small as six or four then have a
part-time assistant Pro rather because
you would probably not have an assistant
for more than a day a week so I think on
balance I think I will vote for it
because it gives us the ability to
actually appoint but certainly from our
group before we wouldn't wish to appoint
because we don't see that that there's
actually a need for it
thank you Council
have you got any more contributions
to the debate
I'm going to ask councilor Stringer as
seconder to Summer
thank you chairman uh well it's actually
rather interesting what we've heard from
the bench in the corner opposite uh the
benches in the corner opposite because
some of us in this room have experience
of having researchers both in
administration and in opposition uh and
as far as I could see in in opposition
we've never used a researcher to write a
speech
what they've researched are the facts
and best practice and accurate details
to form part of the ideas that go into
the speech and I think political
discourse is better served if everyone
on all sides has the best possible
factual information
I think that would serve democracy
so
the fact that this Administration wants
to run the cabinet as lean as we
possibly can want to run our planning
committees as lean while sharing Vice
chair roles as much as we can
recognizing that that planning committee
then has a higher workload but we've
renumerated that
that position to the planning committee
videos and can I while I've got the the
microphone thank our planning committee
for the work they've done so far
it's it's you've had some really tough
decisions so far but thank you I think
you've done some excellent work and we
look forward to making more changes uh
to make you even even better
and wouldn't actually a political system
be really handy in the last 24 hours
we've had our joint local plan part one
now approved by the inspector
and thank you again to all the staff and
to the uh previous administration for
the work you did on that particularly
like to thank uh previous councilor
David Byrne for his work
but actually with the announcements of
government overnight I'd quite like the
researcher at District this morning to
actually tell me what part of our local
plan we need to change within the first
24 hours because the government's now
gone weak on all the climate Ambitions
that we've tried to build into that
joint local plan on behalf of our
residents much of that was based on the
work we've done to get excellent
environmental performance in this
District out of our developers and now
one of the pivotal reasons that we've
extracted that better environment
performance is now being washed away and
we would seek that not to happen and
same with our communities
uh so I will be voting for this because
it's up to us if we chose to have a
researcher seven days a week or six five
days a week we could but you could then
hold us to account on that we think we
can do it in in three days and do an
excellent job it'll be up to you to
choose whether you want to a political
research assistant or not and how many
hours a week up to five days a week that
would take for you to do an excellent
job because we want you to hold us to
account
and and actually come to full Council
meetings with a whole list of questions
on notice
emotions on notice to help push the
policy of this Council you weren't able
to get a motion to this Council perhaps
if you had a research assistant you
could have done that thank you
uh okay
thank you for all the different points
that we made
clearly there's a difference of opinion
about this which I I kind of anticipated
might happen
um I do agree with the points that be
made that say that a political assistant
would add to the quality of the work
that we do and the quality of debate in
this place
um we can review it of course after
after time and it's your job to hold us
to account uh if if that isn't working
but I don't think it's going to cost uh
the the council and and the council
taxpayers any more than the previous
administration and on that basis I'm
happy that uh we go ahead to the vote
thank you
thank you chair that is showing in blue
for councilors to cast their vote
councilman Morgan can I take your vote
please against is it yeah okay
chair that is 24 4.
and 5 against so that is character thank
you
uh
item 16 Council appointments the
appointments have been tabled are there
any further changes to the appointments
non-received could have a proposal
please Council Mellon
could have a second though Council
Mansell
thank you I will now ask the corporate
manager governance and Civic office to
conduct electronic vote
thank you chair that is showing in blue
for you to cast your votes four thank
you I don't know what's going on
councilor Morgan can I take yours for
thank you
so so this is the first time mod.gov's
ever Frozen for me I think I have to
keep closing it and opening it again but
I'm full thank you
councilor Patrick are you having trouble
as well
can I just take how you voted so I can
so
I was just come through actually yeah
thank you
chair that is 29 votes for that is
unanimous
thank you that is carried
uh are there any emotions on notice
thank you well done everybody the next
meeting is on Thursday the 26th of
October
2023 at 5 30 p.m I now close this
meeting